mes chers collègues nous concluons nos
travaux de la matinée toujours en direct
sur le site de l'Assemblée nationale
j'accueille devant la commission
d'enquête Monsieur Alain Bauer vous êtes
notamment parmi de multiples autres
activités ancien président du Conseil
national des activités privées de
sécurité et professeur de criminologie
au Conservatoire national des arts et
métiers où vous avez une chaire depuis
quelques années maintenant vous avez
aussi une longue expérience dans le
domaine de la sécurité qui vous
permettra de nous livrer une
appréciation d'ensemble des événements
sur lesquels nous nous enquêtons
merci aussi d'être présent parce que je
sais que votre emploi du temps est
particulièrement chargé en cette fin
d'année universitaire un questionnaire
vous a préalablement été transmis par
notre rapporteur monsieur Florent
Boudier toutes les questions qu'il
contient ne pourront sans doute pas être
évoqués lors de cette audition donc nous
vous serions extrêmement reconnaissants
si vous pouviez dans un second temps
nous transmettre quelques éléments
écrits par rapport à ce questionnaire
alors comme vous le savez nous nous
penchons sur les événements violents du
printemps en marge de manifestations à
la fois en milieu urbain mais aussi en
milieu rural à la fois sur des mots
d'ordre sociaux et sur la base de
préoccupation environnementale nous
avons besoin de votre expertise pour
cette fois-ci arriver à replacer les
faits brut dans leur contexte voire d'en
distinguer le le sous texte c'est la
raison pour laquelle avant de vous faire
prêter serment je formulerais les deux
premières questions qui nous permettront
de rentrer dans le débat avant
évidemment de passer
la parole dans un deuxième temps à
monsieur le rapporteur ainsi qu'au
collègues qui souhaiteraient évidemment
s'exprimer en premier lieu vous avez
parlé de retour structurel de la
violence qui exprime les effets et
conséquences d'une profonde crise dans
la société si vous employez le terme de
retour
dans une approche qui dépasse les seules
manifestations c'est forcément en lien
avec un passé de référence quel serait
alors cette période d'éclipse de la
violence et valait-elle pour la violence
politique et revendicative sur laquelle
nous travaillons plus spécifiquement au
sein de cette commission d'enquête et en
second lieu les forces de police et de
gendarmerie présentent lors de violences
commises en manifestation sont tiraillés
ils nous l'ont dit à plusieurs reprises
et d'ailleurs difficultés qu'il
rencontre préfèrent l'allemand il
faisait référence encore ce matin entre
l'objectif évidemment indispensable de
maintien de l'ordre qui suppose la mise
à distance et les principes de la police
judiciaire qui supposent d'arriver à
interpeller une personne de manière
pardon de cette redondance individuelle
et spécifique en train de commettre un
délit pour que on puisse lui attribuer
spécifiquement les faits
simplement peut-on espérer concilier ces
exigences contradictoires diriez-vous
que certains pays parviennent mieux que
la France puisque vous avez aussi à
travers votre expertise une vision
internationale assez complète et
gagnerait à être pris pour pour modèle
éventuellement certains pays alors
Monsieur bouaire avant de vous donner la
parole et en application de l'article 6
de l'ordonnance numéro
58-1100 du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires je vais formellement vous
demander de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité donc je vais vous demander de
brancher votre micro de lever la main
droite et de dire je le jure
je le jure je vous en remercie donc sans
tarder je vais vous passer la parole
monsieur le professeur bien merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires et tous ceux ici et
celles et ceux qui font vivre les
commissions parlementaires
fonctionnaires et agents de l'État et de
l'Assemblée je vous remercie d'avoir de
votre invitation vous m'avez envoyé un
très long questionnaire monsieur le
rapporteur donc j'ai prévu d'y répondre
d'abord oralement mais je vous promets
dès que j'aurai fini mais 300 jury
soutenance conseil restreint promotion
des collègues que connaître bien
Monsieur Patrick ketzel que j'ai connu
dans une vie antérieure et dans des
fonctions différentes au ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
je vous promets de vous faire une
réponse écrite et si possible détaillée
mais j'ai eu l'occasion parce que le
réel rattrape toujours le moment
politique comme si votre commission
avait anticipé des événements récents
alors qu'elle s'était plutôt orientée
sur des événements ce qui va peut-être
permettre de faire la boucle y compris
parce que dans votre propre
questionnaire vous aviez justement
procédé à cette mise en cohérence et
surtout en perspective qui est un peu ce
qu'on perd quand on est commentateur de
l'instant ou tout au long de téléréalité
dites informations continue j'y
participe aussi donc j'en parle en
connaissance de cause
le premier élément que je voulais vous
indiquer c'est que la France est un pays
de Jacquerie depuis 1000 ans
il n'y avait pas de commission d'enquête
à l'époque mais il y avait une réalité
structurelle qui est que pour une raison
assez curieuse et presque unique dans le
monde occidental en tout cas la France
est un État nation où l'État a construit
la nation il s'en veut le garant le
structurant
l'organisateur le sachant tout et
faisant tout ou en tout cas tout mieux
que d'autres il n'est pas constitué
depuis en tout cas la transformation et
y compris au moment de la transformation
de l'ancien régime vers la Révolution
française comme un état pas
naturellement décentralisé il n'a pas
choisi d'être Girondins si vous me
permettez ce clin d'oeil monsieur le
rapporteur il y a un enjeu particulier
dans la structuration nationale de de ce
pays qui veut que l'État considère que
toute revendication négociation et
dialogue passe par le rapport de force
et qu'il attend que le rapport de force
se construise pour qu'il y ait un début
de convention de négociation alors j'ai
longtemps travaillé cet anniversaire
secret pour personne avec Michel Rocard
qui sont désolé beaucoup en considérant
qu'on pouvait peut-être commencer à
négocier avant de se taper dessus mais
il se trouve que une sorte de culture
d'État impose qu'on montre ses muscles
d'abord et qu'on discute ensuite et ceci
n'est en rien une nouveauté et
d'ailleurs l'État comme les
organisations sociales paysannes d'abord
puis ouvrière ensuite ont toujours
considéré que après tout c'était le mode
d'emploi il y avait même une
organisation acceptée par partout qui a
été jusqu'au l'ultime moment où ceci a
bien fonctionné se termine 1979 la
grande manifestation des sidérurgistes à
Paris ou le service d'ordre centrale de
la CGT montrait les muscles des
organisations ouvrières les CRS et
gendarmes mobiles montraient les muscles
de l'État une fois que chacun avait
organisé cette espèce de petit tournoi
ou duel avec des règles très strictes et
très précises et bien on entrait dans un
processus de combien vous étiez quel a
été le niveau 2 et la confrontation se
faisait avec un minimum un minimum de
casse mais il y en avait quand même un
peu et on était plutôt dans une relation
symbolique de l'organisation de la
confrontation à partir de 1986 elle est
manifestations étudiantes un événement a
eu lieu qui a continué de dégrader
génériquement la problématique de la
violence en société d'abord une violence
qui s'est installée dans tout le
territoire et qui s'est accentué au
rythme de la décentralisation du deal et
du trafic de stupéfiants avec une
déperdition du contrôle social des
grandes organisations criminelles depuis
la mort de Jean-Jacques Colonna et
l'assassinat de Farid B c'est à dire un
moment où il n'y a plus de contrôle
central des trafics de stupe une
décentralisation massive sur les petits
et moyennes villes et une confrontation
majeure sur la gestion des zones de
chalandise car après tout le trafic de
stupéfiant et l'élément je dirais le
plus extraordinairement développé de
l'économie de marché tout fonctionne à
peu près pareil
intégration verticale l'intégration
horizontale investissement dans la
recherche et développement incentive
pour le petit personnel seul la gestion
de la concurrence est plus définitive
que dans le commerce traditionnel le
problème c'est que la perte de contrôle
a amené massivement des relations
directes du producteur au consommateur
de l'auto-production locale des
frictions sur les fours et les zones de
de chalandise des développements très
curieux
d'accélération des rotations du caïda
local pour l'appeler comme ça sans unité
des termes beaucoup plus désagréables
qui ne relève pas de mon vocabulaire et
donc ce processus a amené une violente
fois plus tellement elle est régulière
les règlements de compte les enlèvements
les violences diverses une certaine
forme de raquette à la fois sociale et
criminels et un développement
d'organisation criminelle au pluriel qui
ne relève plus de la traditionnelle
l'organisation criminelle très verticale
et qui correspondait à peu près à la
manière dont l'état cette estructuré
notamment avec la très forte puissance
des espaces venus du Sud-Est de la
France et particulièrement de de
Marseille qui depuis carbone et Spirito
est une
curiosité nationale mais qui le il est
de moins en moins et c'est un des
premiers éléments à prendre en
considération le deuxième élément à
prendre en conservation à partir de 1986
elle est manifestations étudiantes c'est
l'arrivée soudaine de la nébuleuse alors
je l'ai vécu car il se trouve que
c'était vice-président de l'université
planté en Sorbonne mais aussi à l'époque
responsable
d'un morceau du service d'ordre central
de l'Union nationale des étudiants de
France indépendante et démocratique et
que nous étions au cœur des
manifestations
étudiantes de l'époque et nous avons
arrivés la nébuleuse c'est-à-dire des
lycéens venus d'un peu partout mais
surtout des banlieues des cités des
quartiers qui n'ayant aucune compétence
expérience ou culture de la
manifestation trouvait que c'était très
sympa de venir devant la première ligne
de manifestation pour s'affronter
directement avec les représentants de
l'ordre relativement peu de pillage de
la casse oui des pillages non et une
très grande difficulté à organiser des
éléments une deux rapports de commission
d'enquête de 1986 rappelle ses
événements je ne peux que vous y
renvoyez également l'inspecteur général
Berlioz avec qui nous avons essayé dans
leur propre protection personnelle pour
éviter qu'il soit blessés ou tuer et
notamment après le drame qui a été la
mort tragique de Malik oussekin nous ont
amené à repenser totalement l'idée de
l'organisation des manifestations en
prenant en compte l'arrivée d'amateurs
de la manifestation mais qui était face
à des professionnels du maintien de
l'ordre
et entre 1986 et les gilets jaunes on a
vu des adaptations relatives avec des
problématiques très spécifiques de
violence suite à un événement tragique
notamment dans les banlieues dans une
poursuite réelle ou supposée avec la
police de règlement de compte
d'événements qui amenaient des micros
des micros émeutes
avec des réorientations très subtiles du
maintien de l'ordre avec pour la
première fois des missions communes
sécurité publique PJ notamment après le
CIP les manifestations de 95 donc une
réadaptation permanente des forces de
sécurité mais toujours dans une logique
où on voyait arriver des surfeurs de la
manifestation soit qui venaient pour
s'attaquer aux forces de l'ordre même
quand la manifestation était pacifique
on l'a vu évidemment dans certaines
manifestations retraite peut mais quand
même voulant attaquer les magasins donc
pillage shopping comme on dit mais
réintégrant la manifestation pour éviter
de se faire arrêter voire même en vol et
en détroussant des manifestants
se faufilant parmi la masse et la
position de la police depuis le préfet
depuis 1968 le pile préférée Grimaud a
toujours été mieux vaut une vitrine
cassée qu'une vie brisée et donc la
logique générale a été en évite des
mouvements de foule dramatiques des
morts et des blessés et d'ailleurs il
faut saluer cette logique qui a
parfaitement bien fonctionné jusqu'à
deux événements spécifiques 2005 alors
qui ne sont pas nés d'un contrôle
policier
d'une intervention sur un daily mais de
la peur de deux enfants se réfugient
dans un transformateur électrique et le
traumatisme réel global social qui
provoque lentement mais de manière
extrêmement structurée trois semaines
d'émeutes et une sidération des forces
de sécurité très étonnée à la fois de la
mobilité nouvelle des émeutiers de
l'interaction qui peut exister entre des
gens qui ont une rage par rapport à un
événement tragique et d'autres qui ont
des intérêts plutôt criminel pour
montrer à la police que les territoires
ne sont plus les siens et que même si
elles continuent à y pénétrer sa
présence devient une exception et un
événement qui se traduit mécaniquement
par un besoin de renfort et on est plus
dans une logique de raid que de présence
visibilité proximité ce qui est à la
nature même du gardien de la paix une
transformation du coup des forces de
police qui ont été aussi maltraités que
ne l'a été dans notre pays l'industriel
le sanitaire ou le militaire je pense
que vous avez dû voir passer la loi de
programmation militaire récemment vous
avez vu dans quel état est notre armée
vous avez pu voir dans quel état était
nos hôpitaux et nos services médicaux il
y a eu un développement tragique qui ne
date pas de cette année ni de la semaine
dernière c'est un long processus des
désorganisations de l'État avec cet
effet très particulier c'est qu'en
France c'est l'état ou rien
dans la tête de l'État mais aussi dans
la tête des citoyens et ceci a amené
vraiment un effet de de déstructuration
très très important et qui a amené les
policiers à se considérer à juste titre
d'ailleurs gendarme aussi mais dans des
considérations moins tragiques d'un
point de vue moral comme une sorte de
voiture balai de la société chargée de
résoudre à eux tout seul tout ce qui
n'existait plus dans l'ensemble des
services publics ont fermé au fur et à
mesure parce qu'ils étaient entre
guillemets trop chers trop coûteux trop
compliqué et qu'on aime bien le Grand
Central énorme et massif ce qui explique
par exemple une situation très tendue
qui existe dans les services d'urgence
puisque quand vous avez fermé tout le
reste il y a une sorte de regroupement
de centralisation de ces sujets on avait
fait la même chose pour les collèges et
les lycées c'est-à-dire qu'on passe
brutalement de une petite école de
proximité on passait même les écoles de
proximité ne sont plus qu'elles étaient
mais à des problématiques de
transhumance scolaires de gestion du
temps scolaire et de réorganisation de
l'espace du HLM dans la cour de
récréation avec les mêmes effets de comp
conditions de confrontation de
difficultés ne serait-ce que pour
meubler le vide et donc tous ces
éléments là ont amené à une assez forte
dégradation et 2005 a été un révélateur
sauf que ce révélateur n'a pas été suivi
des faits pas plus mes collègues que
moi-même ni même les collègues qui
étaient mbz dans les services de police
je pense à l'iaei de l'époque etc n'ont
été amenés à établir un véritable
rétexte des émeutes de 2005 elles ont
été tellement difficiles à gérer
tellement compliqué tellement heurté un
aspect politique assez développé et venu
perturber la gestion de l'ensemble la
question de l'état d'urgence qui a été
longuement analysé par des journalistes
politiques ce qui n'est pas mon métier
depuis on montrait à quel point on ne
s'était refusé à essayer d'apprendre
quelque chose les émeutes de 2005 alors
même que pour avoir beaucoup rencontré
notamment des baqueux
eux-mêmes faisaient une analyse sous
forme de un peu cercle de qualité par
je dirais désorganisé amateurs faisaient
une analyse assez juste de ce qui
marchait mal et de ce qui marchait bien
dans leur métier et je pense notamment à
l'ouvrage de mon collègue facein qui
après avoir passé quelques nuits avec
des backers non compris à la fois la
nature l'inutilité et surtout
l'importance de les écouter dans les
propositions qu'ils veulent faire pour à
la fois réduire les confrontations
améliorer l'intérêt de leur métier c'est
assez intéressant qu'on écoute jamais
évidemment le terrain c'est trop
dangereux mais de temps en temps il faut
quand même reconnaître aux policiers
eux-mêmes et les bacs n'apparaissent pas
comme
l'ultimité de la pensée philosophique
mais ils ont une pensée pratique et
opérationnelle qui n'est pas entendu et
qui n'est pas écouté par une partie de
leur propre hiérarchie et en général du
système étatique notamment préfectoral
donc il y a un petit souci et puis ils
sont arrivés les gilets jaunes et ça ça
a été un peu le le pompon de l'ensemble
parce que pour la première fois on a eu
des amateurs de la manifestation face à
des amateurs du maintien de l'or la
déstructuration des services centraux de
sécurité spécialisée c'est-à-dire les
gendarmes mobiles et les CRS leur
réduction en quantité dans chaque
section en nombre de sections dans
chaque compagnie en nombre de compagnies
un bref le la réduction totale et puis
le fait que on en avait tellement peu et
on leur faisait tellement confiance
paradoxalement qu'elles sont devenus des
forces statiques au lieu d'être des
forces mobiles on les a mis statiquement
pour défendre les institutions merci à
celles qui ont défendu le Sénat palais
Luxembourg ou voir le palais de l'Élysée
et quelques institutions ministérielles
que du coup en envoyait à la
confrontation face à des gens qui ne
comprenaient pas pourquoi il fallait
déclarer une manifestation déclarer un
parcours pourquoi c'était interdit
d'aller à l'Elysée ou à l'Arc de
Triomphe ou ailleurs et pendant 52
semaines 52 semaines plus grande
manifestation de l'histoire de ce pays
pourquoi c'était interdit pourquoi on
pouvait pas et face à eux on a employé
tout ce qui était disponible et
essentiellement des gens qui ne sont pas
formés au maintien de l'ordre mais qui
n'avaient pas à l'être ou en tout cas
qui aurait pu l'être mais qui ne l'était
pas avec des équipements de maintien de
l'homme qui sont des équipements
dangereux qui sont des équipements qui
ne sont pas à utiliser dans certains cas
pour le maintien de l'ordre et dont il
n'avait ni l'entraînement ni
l'expérience ni la formation
ceci a amené un très grand nombre de
blessés de violence diverses dont
l'essentiel de la responsabilité n'est
pas aux amateurs des deux camps mais à
l'inorganisation de la désorganisation
et la déstructuration des moyens de
maintien de l'ordre dans ce pays d'un
côté et à la stupéfaction devant ses
gilets jaunes qui sont des gens qui
travaillent la semaine et qui
manifestaient le week-end c'est à dire
une population inédite dans l'histoire
de la manifestation à l'exception
évidemment des pêcheurs des
transporteurs routiers ou des
agriculteurs mais dont les était plutôt
bien connu le tracteur le camion et puis
de temps en temps la manifestation un
peu brutale mais ça appartenait à
l'histoire traditionnelle de la
confrontation sociale sont venus se
rajouter dans tout cela parce que tout
est un effet cumulatif c'est en fait un
mille-feuille l'idée qu'il y aura une
population spécifique pour une
manifestation spécifique qui
organiserait une violence spécifique et
totalement dépassée et d'ailleurs
pendant un temps j'ai dû relire à
plusieurs fois la résolution créant
votre commission d'enquête pour
comprendre pourquoi ces deux dates
particulièrement
avaient un intérêt tant elles sont à la
fois totalement différentes et
totalement conforme et totalement
conforme à une longue histoire Olivier
roi aujourd'hui ou hier explique à ces
longueurs ça fait 40 ans qu'on parle de
la même chose et en ce qui me concerne
je peux dire ça fait 1000 ans qu'on
parle de la même chose et 40 ans qu'on
parle encore plus de la même chose
c'est-à-dire d'une multiplicité
d'acteurs ayant des moyens qui se
ressemblent mais des objectifs
totalement différents les uns surfant
sur les manifestations des autres pour
toute une série de raisons diverses et
c'est le cas par exemple des Black Blocs
depuis Seattle et Gênes et Strasbourg
parce que ça a été un peu voilà et on a
toujours le même phénomène dans les
mêmes conditions et puis de phénomène
sur l'environnemental où je me demande
toujours ce qui peut paraître surprend
ce qui peut paraître surprenant puisque
je rappelle qu'on a déjà eu le Larzac et
Chris Malville avec un mort ça n'est pas
une nouveauté particulière sans parler
de de Sivens ou des événements de
sainte-souligne il y a toujours un
moment où il y a une structuration par
la violence
surfant sur un mouvement plutôt
pacifique mais en disant nous on veut
aller plus loin alors sainte Soline
étant un cas particulier parce que c'est
la première fois à ma connaissance
que j'ai pu constater en lisant un grand
journal du soir qui parlait désormais le
matin que il y avait on pouvait
s'inscrire de manière volontaire sur un
petit document où on était des gentils
manifestants des un peu énervé
manifestants ou des très très énervé
manifestants pour organiser une sorte de
Koh-Lanta de la manifestation avec totem
obligatoire et on va mettre le drapeau
sur le château qui m'a paru est une
curiosité alors là extrêmement nouvelle
je reconnais qu'effectivement ça ne se
line de ce point de vue là pas du point
de vue des affrontements ni des
manifestations ni des manifestants ni ce
qui est passé mais de l'organisation
structurelle où on pourrait
s'autodéfinir en fonction de son niveau
de violence présumé était une nouveauté
je ne sais pas si c'est un progrès mais
en tout cas c'est une curiosité et puis
on arrive évidemment à toute une série
de manifestation où le calme revient
c'est-à-dire le mouvement social on va
prendre le contrôle de ses propres
manifestations ce qui n'était pas le cas
de celle du 1er mai en général pour
arriver à des manifestations structurées
et ordonnées et où éventuellement à la
fin de la fin du processus on explique
que
d'accord on a été ordonné on a rien
cassé ou assez peu on a bien contrôlé sa
MAIF mais on obtient rien alors que
Ligier les jaunes eux en cassant tout
obtenu quelque chose fin de résumé de
leaders syndicaux disant on a quand même
un petit sujet dans la relation avec
l'État plus on est plus on respecte les
règles dans l'ordre et moi on est écouté
plus on entre dans le désordre et le
chaos plus on est écouté et puis arrive
le phénomène alors très récent vous
m'excuserez déborder mais enfin on va
pas faire comme si les derniers
événements n'avaient pas eu lieu en tout
cas je ne pense pas que ça soit la
logique de la représentation nationale
c'est l'arrivée d'un phénomène tout à
fait nouveau d'accélération en intensité
en rajeunissement en violence en
radicalité ce mot ne veut rien dire mais
on fait comme s'il avait un une
signification
des événements liés à la tragique de ce
jeune homme dans son véhicule parce que
pour la première fois on est passé de la
rage au pillage en moins de 48 heures il
n'y a pas eu un effet d'étalement ça a
été beaucoup plus intense que 2005
beaucoup plus rapide que 2005 dans des
conditions beaucoup plus étalées que
2005 je pense particulièrement à
Marseille qui avait échappé à ce
phénomène où là il a été surconcentré je
sais pas si c'est un des phénomène de
rattrapage ou un effet dû à des
événements qui avaient précédé bref une
situation de désagrégation et de
dégradation voilà pour ce qui est
l'archétype général vous m'avez posé une
question sur la violence le camp
dégradation retour alors moi j'ai une
vision assez simple de la violence c'est
la mort je considère qu'il y a qu'un
seul élément stable dans l'idée générale
de ce comment on gère la violence d'une
société c'est le missile il y en a deux
entrées pour le missile d'ailleurs il y
a homicide est tentatives d'homicides
une tentative d'homicide c'est juste un
homicide raté soit dû à l'incompétence
du tireur ou de l'assassin soit
l'efficacité des
euh qui eux ont directement dans les
16000 incriminations possibles et
variations du code pénal là on a un
outil qui est assez intéressant parce
qu'il est sur l'intention et l'intention
et l'effet et donc on a cet outil et il
montre une très forte dégradation de la
volonté de tuer de l'idée qu'on va tuer
et du passage à l'acte cet élément là
m'indique que au cours des 10 dernières
années car c'est une longue dégradation
mais c'est une réelle dégradation et au
cours des trois dernières années en
particulier on a atteint un pic
du passage à l'axe c'est à dire on
tiromptue on frappe avant de discuter et
on n'est pas dans un processus gradué de
monter en violence on est dans un
processus on monte tout de suite en
violence et puis ensuite on voit et je
constate simplement ce phénomène qui me
paraît particulièrement inquiétant et
qui est un signal indicateur d'une sorte
de violence sociale générale qui n'est
pas simplement lié au règlement de
compte entre malfaiteurs ou aux conflits
sur la question des stupéfiants mais qui
est une problématique générale où on
voit des agressions contre les élus des
agressions contre les mers les
agressions contre les médecins et mon
indicateur le plus emblématique c'est
des agressions contre les pompiers parce
que pour à peu près tous les uniformes
on peut expliquer qui sont racistes qui
sont faciles qui sont mal polis qui tue
toi tout le monde qui contrôle les
identités bref ils ont tous les défauts
du monde sauf quand on a besoin d'eux
mais les pompiers n'entre dans aucune de
ces catégories il sauve les gens ils
atteignent les feux voilà et pourtant
ils sont de plus en plus agressés en
mission et surtout en guet-apens et le
guet-apens change tout dans la relation
qu'on peut avoir avec la violence que on
arrive de manière impromptue au milieu
d'un deal un peu difficile et que
malencontreusement ça crée une relation
un peu brutale par la surprise générale
et le défouraillage bon ça fait
malheureusement partie des risques du
métier et il arrive que ça se traduise
mal mais dans ce cas précis quand on
fait venir spécifiquement des policiers
ou des pompiers quand on fait brûler des
officines des pharmacies des cabinets
médicaux quand on agresse du personnel
médical qui est en train de traiter aux
urgences un des copains ou un des amis
ou je ne sais un proche ou un ennemi
d'ailleurs de celui qui est là on est
dans tout à fait autre chose et ce
problème là il est effectivement d'un
grand retour de la violence comme
élément structurant alternatif de la
société on est passé là dans un
processus qui est relativement nouveau
et de fortes dégradations quant à votre
question sur le benchmarking étranger je
crois monsieur le Président parce que
j'essaie de ne pas me perdre
dans ce que je suis en train de vous
dire il y a effectivement des niveaux
vraiment différent une société très dure
et très heurtée aux États-Unis
d'Amérique où effectivement je suis le
conseil du noypidy et où j'ai vu à la
fois les effets d'avant de pendant et de
depuis black live matter's mais aussi
dans un certain nombre d'autres villes
où je suis requis là plutôt pour des
raisons académiques comme à Los Angeles
mais il m'arrive aussi d'aller voir ce
qui se passe à Boston qui a peut-être un
pardon à Chicago qui était un modèle de
police de community policing de police
de proximité au sens large et dans la
dégradation et le niveau d'homicidité a
parfaitement explosé depuis plusieurs
années
alors que New York tenait le coup c'est
beaucoup dégradé au cours des trois
dernières années essentiellement dû à
des effets cumulés de covid plus BLM et
puis mise en cause évidemment de la
structure même du noypili dans ses
activités de de maintien de l'ordre et
de contrôle des identités c'est aussi un
des un des sujets qui a été porté en
critique des services de de police pour
des raisons alors qu'ils sont assez
intéressants parce que aux États-Unis on
avait à la fois une analyse statistique
une analyse démographique qui visait à
permettre de considérer qu'effectivement
il y avait une une suractivité du
contrôle d'identité et du contrôle du
port d'arme puisque New York avait une
régulation relative
sur ces questions mais on voit
apparaître un certain nombre de
violences et des meute on les voit dans
la brutalité de ce qui se passe parfois
lors de manifestations à Bruxelles nos
amis allemands qui sont très
décentralisés ont une vision plus
relativiste du sujet et notamment de la
gestion de la désescalade par la
désescalade c'est un peu différent les
Anglais ont assez bien maîtrisé leur
problématiques mais je rappelle que tous
ces pays ont une différence majeure il
n'y a pas de police centrale d'État qui
fait tout chacun a son mode opératoire
sa capacité d'adaptation sa logique ça
doctrine ce qui est centralisé c'est la
lutte contre le crime organisé et le
terrorisme et effectivement ça n'est pas
comparable avec les logiques nationales
qu'on peut voir aujourd'hui voilà
monsieur le président
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Professeur
déjà des éléments très très précis dans
dans votre intervention je vais passer
la parole à Monsieur le Rapporteur
pardon
merci monsieur le professeur pour votre
intervention à la fois vous avez montré
me semble-t-il que notre culture
politique
offrait un terrain plutôt favorable à
une forme pardon je vais empris un terme
que vous avez disqualifié une forme de
radicalisation y compris politique et
enfin partisane pour être plus précis et
donc elle mesure nous sommes entrés dans
une phase depuis
une trentaine une quarantaine d'années
si je vous suis de violences
structurelles même si vous considérez
tout ceci ce fait dans une certaine
continuité historique
quelques questions
la première est-ce que vous voyez des
connexions d'analyses d'observation de
constat connexion entre les groupuscules
violents dont nous étudions les méthodes
d'action à l'occasion des rassemblements
dans la période de temps qui nous est
imparti
et les émeutes urbaines récentes vous
avez fait référence à un niveau de
violence assez généralisé mais est-ce
que vous voyez des connexions plus
spécifiques de groupe d'individus
méthode d'action est-ce qu'il y a des
liens ou est-ce qu'on séparation de
comportements et de situations qui fait
que nous sommes face à des événements
tout à fait distincts deuxième question
est-ce que au fond notre schéma national
de maintien de l'ordre notre culture du
maintien de l'ordre est en soi un
facteur de violence évidemment c'est un
débat très présent depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois mais certains des
éléments d'analyse que vous avez
communiqué exprimé devant la commission
d'enquête laisse entendre que vous vous
êtes prêt à assumer cette forme
d'analyse mais peut-être me suis je
trompais et je pense qu'il est
intéressant d'avoir votre opinion sur ce
sujet et puis troisième question une
forme de rebond par rapport à l'audition
précédente il y a de façon générale sur
la cause environnementale cette fois-ci
sur les mouvements environnementalistes
une sorte de montée en durcissement
assez général en tout cas c'est
l'analyse des journalistes que nous
avions il y a quelques instants devant
nous qui va de la représentation
politique
institutionnalisée jusqu'à des modes
d'action violents
et violence au sens dégradation
matérielle et pas uniquement violence
envers les personnes même si vous l'avez
résumé la violence à la question de
l'homicide et je comprends très bien
pourquoi vous en faites un dictateur à
la fois pertinent constant et
utile voilà est-ce que c'est une analyse
que vous faites également c'est autour
d'un nouvel entrant si j'ose dire dans
la violence politique et la violence
matérielle physique qui est la cause
environnementaliste est-ce qu'il y a un
continuum entre la représentation
politique et des méthodes des méthodes
violentes sainte Soline est-il
représentative de cette forme
d'évolution
ou pas voilà les quelques questions que
je souhaitais poser en première approche
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur et
pour pour tirer le fil par rapport à ce
que ce que vient dire sur la porteur
les débats et les auditions que nous
avons pu avoir jusqu'à présent montrent
aussi
des formes de paradoxe c'est-à-dire que
quand vous regardez simplement ce qu'on
appelle la désobéissance civile
historiquement
vous connaissez les États-Unis celle-ci
était fortement attachés justement à des
méthodes non violentes et là où nous
sommes un peu étonnés par ce qui semble
se développer c'est que comment dire se
distinguer n'opère plus c'est à dire que
on va aller jusqu'à
légitimer des actions violentes en
faisant référence un corpus idéologique
qui précédemment était à 180 degrés de
de de cela quoi donc
donc et et et par vous être conséquent
aussi une sorte de de d'évolution dans
le dans ce qui est considéré comme comme
étant un impératif parce que par exemple
l'une des argumentations que nous voyons
arriver c'est de dire mais regardez à un
moment donné il s'agissait de de comment
dire de de ce se battre pour des droits
fondamentaux et en fait aujourd'hui on
fait ce glissement considérant que
évidemment les causes environnementales
sont de même nature que les causes
autour des des droits de l'homme
merci alors
il n'y a pas de connexion entre des
groupes divers ayant des opinions
diverses et des enjeux diverses il y a
des effets d'opportunité et d'aubaine
ça ne nécessite aucune connexion ou
aucune coordination
particulière les seuls opérateurs
véritablement structurés dans ces
affaires étant les éléments criminels et
les dealers qui au bout d'un moment
malgré les évolutions des dispositifs de
transport et de livraison à domicile
entre une pizza et un burger ont encore
besoin de maintenir un certain nombre de
points de distribution et de contrôle de
ces points de distribution de la même
manière que des contrôles des
dispositifs de livraison d'ailleurs qui
justifient selon eux du fait de la
concurrence et de la compétition brutale
qui peut s'exercer la disponibilité
d'armes de guerre qu'on a toujours pas
vu sortir dans la réalité pour l'instant
malgré quelques tirs ici là qu'il faut
pas sous-estimer mais pas dans les qu'on
indique c'est à dire que paradoxalement
le dealer est à la fois un élément
perturbateur et un élément régulateur de
son univers de son univers territorial
donc oui il y a des effets d'aubaine et
des effets d'opportunités en te des
groupes ayant des opinions totalement
différentes et non ils ne sont pas
coordonnées par contre il recrutent
c'est-à-dire que on a pu arriver voir
arriver par exemple
des yellow black c'est à dire des gilets
jaunes alors je ne disqualifie pas le
terme radicalisé je dis juste qu'il ne
veut scientifiquement pas dire grand
chose mais que nous l'utilisons tous
comme s'il voulait dire quelque chose je
ne pense pas que les radicaliser ou les
radicaux qui pour moi sont des messieurs
à barbe blanche ayant une forte
proportion à la laïcité soit des
radicals qui cassaient les machines
au XIXe siècle en Grande-Bretagne vous
voyez mais bon ce mot étant dans le dans
le débat public on va faire comme si
mais en la matière
le passage de l'un à l'autre
c'est-à-dire l'idée que au fur et à
mesure d'une sorte de glissement
vieillesse technicité de la
manifestation certains gilets jaunes
très amateurs sont passés dans l'idée
que le black bloc c'était quand même
super sympa et que ça pouvait répondre à
un certain nombre de préoccupations
socio-politique qui permettait une
appréhension de la doctrine politique
une politisation au sens là
scientifique du du terme quelque chose
qu'on pourrait apprendre à l'IEP il y a
là toute une série d'éléments qu'il faut
prendre en considération mes connexions
interconnexion relation entre
organisation
coupola de la désorganisation et de la
manifestation non pas à ma connaissance
et je crois pas qu'on ait eu d'éléments
ou d'exemples mais par contre on a des
espèces d'accord
provisoires d'un moment particulier
jusqu'au moment où le plus fort et le
plus armé explique qu'il faut passer à
autre chose et c'est celui qui a en
général
le dernier mot snmo je vais prendre un
exemple assez simple il y a eu avant le
préfet allemand et après le préfet
allemand donc il y a eu plusieurs
préfets le snmo m'a pas changé et chacun
de ces préfets a été considéré comme
Barbe bleue pour les uns ou le
Rédempteur universel de la paix civile
pour les autres alors c'est toujours un
peu compliqué quand le sMMO ne change
pas le sMMO en fait il est
extraordinairement adaptable et flexible
il prend en compte des problématiques
très spécifiques et très particulières
par exemple j'ai été un des militants de
la dissolution du peloton des Voltigeurs
motorisés bon je rappelle historiquement
que c'était un truc artisanal fait par
des amateurs entre un moniteur
d'éducation physique et un motard armé
d'un bidule qui s'était terminé
tragiquement dans des conditions
insupportables et donc après la fin des
PVM il y a eu un colloque c'est la seule
et unique fois qu'il y a eu un colloque
organisé par préfecture de police de
Paris sur le thème et après
parce que c'est bien de supprimer les
PVPs c'est même très bien mais on peut
pas les remplacer par rien
et donc l'absence de doctrine
d'imagination de volonté malgré ce qui
s'exprimait au niveau local y compris
par une partie de la hiérarchie de la
préfecture de police amené mécaniquement
à une incapacité d'adaptation
des responsables du maintien de l'ordre
à la pratique de ceux qui créent le
désordre et c'est tout le problème or
ils avaient tous des idées dont la
plupart étaient parfaitement compatible
avec le maintien des libertés
individuelles la défense des droits et
voilà l'idée même d'ailleurs d'avoir des
unités mixes police judiciaires sécurité
publique était probablement ce qu'on
pouvait faire de mieux puisque pour la
première fois on remettait la procédure
dans les opérations au lieu de la faire
venir après en essayant de d'enrober
allez des trucs étaient plus ou moins
bien fait et plus ou moins bien écrit et
plus ou moins bien restitué la perte par
exemple des secrétariats aux procédures
la perte de
dimensions d'intensité de qualité
d'efficacité des métiers de la police
judiciaire de proximité je parle celle
de sécurité publique je parle pas des
grands offices centraux à amener
mécaniquement à une déperdition d'un
certain nombre de modes opératoires et
de gestes professionnels qui n'a pas
facilité les choses surtout quand on est
non plus face à des professionnels de la
manifestation qui en toutes les règles
et tous les usages et d'ailleurs qui ont
même le petit coup le numéro de
téléphone qui va bien pour régler les
petits contentieux qui se traduisent
entre les grands services d'ordre des
organisations syndicales et la
préfecture de ou les préfectures de
police il y en a qu'une qui en avait
qu'une seule à l'époque où les
organisations policières et puis
l'arrivée de plein de nouveaux qui
apprennent en marchant et dans des
conditions extrêmement extrêmement
difficiles donc je crois pas que le snmo
sont après je peux vous dire par exemple
que j'ai lu beaucoup de choses sur la
loi de 2017 je suis d'accord avec Maître
Liénard qui est un grand défenseur des
policiers que cette loi est inutile
complexe mais qui c'est pas un drame ce
qui est un drame c'est la circulaire
DGPN quand on l'a dit par rapport à la
circulaire des GGM l'une est protectrice
des droits a explique la victime défense
et la concomitance et l'autre est un
truc où je lui mis quand même trois fois
à la relire pour essayer de comprendre
ce qu'elle voulait dire il se trouve que
c'est mon métier ce qui est plus
inquiétant peut-être donc je pense que
si déjà la DGPN faisait un effort de
rédaction de sa circulaire avec des
opérateurs de pour comprendre ce que ils
en comprennent et comment on pourrait
faire en sorte que ça ne se reproduise
pas dans ces conditions là c'est à dire
que la légitime défense soit garantie
aux policiers mais pas tout refus
d'obtempérer donne droit à tirer ce qui
a été dit ce qui a même été vendu au
moment de l'interprétation je parle pas
de la rédaction je parle bien de
l'interprétation de la loi malgré cet
amendement de dernière minute qui n'a
rien fait pour améliorer les choses on
peut par exemple comprendre que donc le
snmo c'est moi un problème de snmo qu'un
problème d'adaptation du sMMO ou du
réalité du coup et quand vous avez une
une manifestation tranquille vous avez
un maintien de l'ordre tranquille c'est
pas le maintien de l'ordre qui crée le
désordre quasiment jamais je n'ai pas
d'exemple particulier de maintien de
l'ordre qui crée le désordre j'ai des
moments où des des gens qui pensent
avoir des droits particuliers à aller à
tel endroit ou à tel autre sans avoir en
changeant de parcours trouve anormal que
les forces du maintien de l'ordre leur
disent ben non tu peux pas aller là où
c'est pas possible et donc là où se crée
des des rugosités et des confrontations
il y a un vrai problème sur les
manifestations interdites et
l'interprétation qu'on peut avoir de la
préparation à l'interdiction d'une
manifestation en disant bah si elle est
interdite personne ne peut y aller même
en faisant semblant dit flâner en
sifflotant enfin il y a toute une série
de sujets dans l'application de règles
qui concerne plutôt la préfectorale et
les moyens de l'appliquer là je pense
plus particulièrement au lion Turin ou à
quelques autres manifestations moins
intenses que sainte Soline mais qui pose
problème simplement dans
l'interprétation et l'application de la
loi je rappelle qu'il y a eu des
manifestations pendant l'état d'urgence
après les attentats comme si de rien
n'était et donc il y a aussi un moment
où il faut savoir où se situe l'option
de l'État soit il considère que le droit
de manifester et supérieur à beaucoup
d'autres et je pense que c'est un droit
constitutionnel qu'il faut défendre et à
ce moment-là on interdit que très
modérément les manifestations soyez
concerts qu'il faut les interdire et il
prend les moyens de l'interdiction le
problème c'est qu'il est toujours entre
deux alors le passage du en même temps à
l'entre-deux pardonnez-moi ce jeu de
mots faciles et toujours un peu
compliqué et ça fait toujours beaucoup
plus mal aux adducteurs que autre chose
quant aux problèmes d'environnement de
violences environnementales alors comme
je le disais la première date c'était
Larzac ça ne date pas d'hier et ça ne
s'est pas bien terminé pour l'État en
tout cas pour le camp d'entraînement est
militaire qu'elle se mêle ville un mort
Notre-Dame-des-Landes a été une grande
répétition générale qui a duré
extrêmement longtemps et sur lequel la
posture de l'État qui ne savait plus
très bien où il se situait y compris le
respect des référendums locaux ou de la
position des des habitants à amener
mécaniquement à ne plus savoir qui
disait quoi et quelle était la position
qui était tenue ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut aller jusqu'au bout de
l'affrontement quand c'est inutile mais
on sent bien qu'il y a là une
déperdition de la capacité de l'autorité
de l'État
qui pour moi n'est pas absolue mais
enfin il en faut quand même un petit peu
quoi autrement on a plus besoin d’état
on peut se faire une autorisation
sympathique et peut-être une
auto-gestion qui aurait beaucoup plus à
Michel Rocard enfin encore que je n'en
suis pas sûr parce que c'était un homme
d'ordre malgré tout mais il y a là un
phénomène qui n'est pas nouveau et qui
en plus n'est pas la poursuite de la
politique par d'autres moyens au
contraire pendant très longtemps sur le
modèle allemand les représentants
politiques de l'écologie ou de
l'environnement on choisit de devenir
des opérateurs du système politique
implanté dans ces poétique ayant des
élus des ministres des membres du
gouvernement et essayant justement de de
supprimer la partie la plus violente de
l'activité de
[Musique]
désobéissance civile qui n'avait jamais
été en France en tout cas
particulièrement tranquille les
processus venus du matmagandi ou de
Martin Luther King ne sont pas des
produits nationaux ça c'est de
l'importation gentille et une partie du
problème a été justement l'effet gilet
jaune/
manifestation retraite
très dur très violent on obtient ce
qu'on veut grands débat des milliards
dans l'idée générale je ne dis pas que
c'est la réalité et puis chacun sait que
ce n'est pas totalement la réalité et
puis on manifeste tranquillement
gentiment on a des revendications et on
nous entend pas en nous écoute pas donc
on va casser parce que peut-être que ça
va marcher et donc ce processus là il
marche aussi pour tout le monde et
d'ailleurs une partie importante de
l'établishment
des vers et très probablement très
préoccupé y compris par le fait que de
leur leader mais c'est pas vrai fait
particulièrement bien recevoir puisque
devenu quasiment un collabo du point de
vue d'une partie
[Musique]
la perte de confiance de respect
du monde politique du monde médiatique
de mes collègues enseignants je suis pas
sûr que nous-mêmes ayons
particulièrement été d'une totale
efficacité dans nos dialogues internes
sur durant le coronavirus la science de
ce point de vue là s'est suicidé en
direct donc je ne vais pas ramener ma
fraise en expliquant que nous sommes au
dernier en fait il reste plus grand
chose et les élus de locaux étaient
justement ce qui permettait encore de
tenir une partie du sujet on sent bien
que il y a une aussi très grande
dégradation donc je crois que il y a en
la matière un problème de violentisation
générale de la société et pour certaines
dans une certaine partie d'entre elles
notamment sur la question
environnementale un sens de l'urgence et
du besoin qui passe par des opérations
de sabotage des opérations extrêmement
symboliques je pense au musée notamment
mais aussi par la violence comme si
c'était
le dernier outil alors disposition et il
est très très difficile d'établir un
dialogue avec ces militants les plus
extrêmes parce qu'il vous explique de
manière extrêmement rationnelle pourquoi
l'extrême est devenu la manière
ordinaire de manifester parce qu'on a
plus le temps de faire autre chose et
que on a perdu 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans 40
ans je parle sur la question
environnementale et que ben maintenant
c'est plus le moment de discuter on a
essayé ça ça a pas marché on passe à
autre chose et c'est souvent un
mécanisme voilà tout mouvement social
accouche d'une génération radicale d'une
avant-garde violente et parfois d'action
qui utilisent aussi la terreur c'est
malheureusement une tradition et alors
là dans la plupart des pays qui les ont
connus pour des raisons diverses mais
qui ont toujours eu ça ça s'appelait les
années de plomb ou la stratégie de
l'attention et bien ceci existe il faut
pas le sous-estimer et c'est possible
sur la question environnementale comme
ça l'était sur les questions sociales ou
industrielles ou purement
de ce fameux passé qui ne passait pas de
la prière
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Professeur je
me tourne vers les collègues est-ce
qu'il y a des oui monsieur taverne je
vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur le professeur donc
déjà merci pour tout tous vos propos
avec une certaine
rationalité
je pense que la réalité du terrain et
puis votre hommage aussi au policiers
parce qu'effectivement nous les avons
pas écouté pendant des années alors
qu'ils ont une stratégie une vision une
technicité qui est malheureusement a été
souvent dénigré par une certaine
hiérarchie je ne mets pas toute la
hiérarchie bien évidemment dans le même
sac alors moi j'aurais une question
notamment sur votre vision
nous avons auditionné
des journalistes qui avec leur offre
leur ouvrage
l'affrontement qui vient
ils ont utilisé des formules
particulièrement clair explicite
radicalisation durcissement du mouvement
écologiste affrontement haute
confrontation donc
je pense que nous allons très
certainement vers malheureusement une
amplification des violences notamment
concernant les grands les grands projets
c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois vous
utilisez le mot compétition dans
certains territoires
vous évoquez également les violences
envers les forces de l'ordre
vous parlez d'une violence structurelle
et moi c'est vrai que pendant des années
on m'a dit oui oui ça s'est calmé
jusqu'à la prochaine fois
et pensez-vous justement par rapport à
tout cela par rapport aux violences qui
seront exercées alors nous espérons pas
mais il y a des événements qui arrivent
la Coupe du monde de rugby les Jeux
Olympiques donc il va falloir
extrêmement vigilant et c'est la raison
pour laquelle cette commission d'enquête
elle a bien venue puisque il faudrait
mettre un coup d'accélérateur pour
éviter
que nos reparlions de ce même sujet dans
10 ans dans 15 ans à votre avis est-ce
qu'il faudrait parce que vous avez fait
le rapport avec les gilets jaunes
effectivement ou pendant les gilets
jaunes nous avons envoyé des amateurs du
maintien à Londres face à des amateurs
également des violences
est-ce qu'il à votre avis il faudrait
véritablement augmenter les effectifs
des unités forces mobiles CRS et
gendarmes mobiles avec des moyens
adaptés notamment des moyens
intermédiaires puisque excusez-moi
monsieur le Président mais les gendarmes
et les policiers nous ont dit en fait
plus les violences étaient importantes
envers les forces de l'ordre
plus en fait les moyens intermédiaires
étaient retirés
et notamment pour garder cette fameuse
distance ensuite votre votre avis
concernant la formation continue
qui pour moi est un est un sujet
essentiel puisque vous parlez également
du 435 moi je me souviens qu'à l'époque
quand j'étais instructeur qu'on a eu ce
435 parce que je connais bien l'enfant
qui est en art c'était une Tunisie à gaz
et malheureusement il n'y a pas eu
suffisamment d'explications
sur ce 435 donc voilà il va falloir
peut-être éviter à de reconnaître de
nouvelles erreurs donc voilà cette
vision concernant les effectifs la
formation en fait la vision que vous
avez par rapport au prochain événements
et l'amplification des violences merci
je vous remercie et je vous repasse tout
de suite la parole monsieur le
professeur merci monsieur le député
vous êtes enfin connaisseur du sujet de
l'interne je crois mais non ce que je
veux dire c'est que
on a eu une politique de déflation
considérable des forces mobiles à la
fois en créant deux situations une
réduction
structurelle
section compagnie donc bref on a tout
réduit donc évidemment ça pose des
problèmes en termes d'efficacité on a
pensé qu'elle ne servait plus à
grand-chose et en plus en a transformé
des forces mobiles en unité sédentaire
donc évidemment à un moment il faut
avoir une sorte de cohérence général le
problème n'est pas le nombre je dis
souvent que nous n'avons pas besoin de
plus de policiers nous avons surtout
besoin de mieux de policiers et en
répartition territoriale et en
spécialisation et vous avez raison de le
souligner et en formation initiale la
réduction de la formation initiale est
un danger absolu en formation dans la
relation avec les citoyens quel qu'il
soit il sait pas seulement une question
de tutoiement et puis dans évidemment la
formation permanente notamment à l'usage
d'outils dont ils n'ont ni l'habitude ni
l'expérience ni la compétence vous avez
évidemment vous avez bien vu passer
entre le flash-ball et le LBD nous ne
parlons pas de la même chose ni en
termes de distance ni en termes de
puissance ni en termes non plus de
diamètre l'une était une un équipement
pour repousser l'autre était un
équipement pour taper faut bien le dire
mais on ne peut pas expliquer la
réduction du format qui permet juste des
borniers les gens comme si c'était
normal je dis pas que le coca soit
essentiellement mieux quand on le
retrouve sur la tête mais vous avez pu
constater que depuis les événements
récents on a vu arriver des effets
pervers de tir de LBD et malencontreux
et dont je ne suis pas sûr de savoir
exactement dans quelles conditions
étaient mais l'enquête le dira est donc
on va pas s'avancer mais on voit
beaucoup qu'il y a beaucoup de tirs dans
les effets involontaires sont liés à la
mauvaise maîtrise et à la mauvaise
compréhension d'un outil qui est donné
un peu comme si c'était la même chose
qu'un tir un fusil à eau quoi donc on a
un problème majeur dans ça et la qualité
des effectifs la qualité de la formation
des effectifs est un élément absolument
ma je pense que un très grand nombre de
policiers qui sont aujourd'hui ou de
parfois de gendarmes en moins grand
nombre mais pour des raisons de de ce
point de vue là de meilleure efficacité
de meilleurs soucis de de qualité de la
formation et de la formation continue
est un élément qui doit être
impérativement représentant il a fallu
regarder des effectifs après en avoir
perdu beaucoup pour de mauvaises raisons
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
comptables de Bercy mais aux dernières
nouvelles ça a jamais fait un financier
ou un politique et on gère pas la
politique du pays avec une feuille Excel
ou pas seulement en tout cas si les
naturellement essentiel d'avoir un bon
contrôle du denier public une fois qu'on
a déstructuré à peu près tout ce qui
fait souveraineté faut pas s'étonner que
ça n'existe plus d'autant qu'on n'est
pas un spectateur dans cette affaire on
est un complice d'une opération qui a
désorganisé l'industrie la sécurité le
sanitaire et le militaire je l'ai dit et
je le répète parce qu'à un moment faudra
bien que ça rentre dans la tête de ceux
qui s'étonnent des effets de leur propre
action mais sur le fond on peut
parfaitement redéployer
restructurer reformer au sens de la
formation une partie importante des
dispositifs et je suis très étonné
d'ailleurs
ça fait de nombreuses années que je
forme des gendarmes des militaires et
même des agents de service de
d'analystes du renseignement et je suis
très étonné du retard de la police
nationale par rapport à toutes les
autres institutions en charge de l'ordre
sur cette question comme si il
apparaissait impossible d'avoir une DRH
qui s'appelle DRH et une direction de la
formation qui fasse de la formation
depuis le le départ du contrôleur
général Perez on sent bien que ceci est
devenu un aspect assez secondaire de la
vie et qu'on est plutôt dans il y en a
beaucoup qui partent il y en a beaucoup
il faut donc en faire entrer beaucoup on
passe d'événements alors vous avez des
phénomènes assez intéressants période
Poniatowski après ponyatowski évidemment
modification des régimes horaires après
l'arrivée de la gauche donc évidemment
on perd beaucoup d'effectifs sans perdre
d'effectif on perd des des effectifs en
mais on les remplace pas vraiment puis
on les réorganise on les restructure
les 40 heures les 39 heures ça monte ça
descend le non-paiement des heures
supplémentaires le stop invraisemblable
de supplémentaires non payé j'ai des
racines ministère de l'intérieur était
un entrepreneur privé il sera en prison
d'un point de vue de la résistation
sociale voilà donc des événements qui
montrent une profonde
des amours du cœur de ce qu'est le
ministère de l'Intérieur c'est-à-dire
des humains
voilà temps en temps il y a des grands
ministres de la police il arrive qu'il y
a des grands ministres des policiers
plus difficilement avoir les deux mais
c'est on sent bien l'immense difficulté
qu'il y a et donc la situation de de
peine morale sociale
organisationnelle matériel
des policiers est un sujet de
préoccupation alors moi je pense que
dans cette situation
on a plutôt un ministère de l'Intérieur
plus compréhensif et plus opératif qu'on
a pu la voir
parmi de certains de ces prédécesseurs
on va dire mais il y a un enjeu de
doctrine de structuration de retour de
ce qu'est la mission est gardien de la
paix et maintient l'ordre en arrêtant de
tout mélanger la polyvalence l'idée de
polyvalence a tué le métier terre c'est
bien d'avoir plein de métiers possibles
mais en fait pas tout en même temps on
peut pas en même temps faire présence
visibilité proximité renseignement
maintien de l'ordre sortie d'école
anti-criminalité avec les mêmes et avec
aller 10% des effectifs la nuit où il y
a 50 à 60% de la criminalité et puis
désaffectations horaires et
territoriales des moyens matériels et
humains qui sont toujours marqués par
une certaine curiosité dans les
implantations on va dire ça comme ça
donc je crois qu'il y a un vrai enjeu de
de faire de la police un nouvel outil de
gardien de la paix accepté par la
population en situation
d'enracinement dans les espaces y
compris les plus difficiles évidemment
ça nécessite un gros effort
qualitatif c'est pas un effort
quantitatif de ce point de vue là et et
je pense qu'il y a là un enjeu majeur
alors je sais que l'actuel titulaire du
métier de premier flic de France en est
parfaitement conscient je ne suis pas
sûr que ça soit allé jusqu'à Bercy mais
il faut jamais désespérer de la vie
merci beaucoup monsieur le professeur
nous vous remercions aussi de la qualité
de cet échange et de vos propos qui sont
très très éclairants également ce que
vous venez de dire sur la place de
l'humain dans un ministère comme celui
de l'Intérieur en tout cas
soyez remercier pour pour cette
contribution alors mes chers collègues
nous avons terminé notre matinée
d'audition nous nous retrouvons dès
lundi 17h pour une semaine prochaine une
semaine très intense et ça sera là aussi
l'occasion
nous avons éventuellement l'audition du
ministre de l'Intérieur il faut qu'on
voit si celle-ci sera ou non confirmé
voilà en tout cas merci beaucoup et je
lève la séance merci